para llevar a la política siempre ha
sido un asunto de familia cuando se
convirtió en ministro jefe de punjab por
primera vez en 1990 tomó el relevo de su
hermano mayor nahuas que acababa de ser
elegido primer ministro de pakistán
nawaz sharif fue reelegido en 1997 antes
de que un golpe militar los derrocar a
dos años después y obligará a toda la
familia a exiliarse pero los hermanos
sharif tenían ganas de más a su regreso
a pakistán casi una década después
chivas fue reelegido dos veces ministro
de punjab mientras que en aguas se
convirtió en primer ministro por tercera
vez y cuando fue destituido por el
tribunal supremo en 2018 por acusaciones
de corrupción nawaz sharif propuso su
hermano pequeño para sucederle al frente
de la liga musulmana
propongo el nombre de mohamed se va a
salir en contraste con el enfoque de su
hermano más indiferente se va se forja
una reputación de líder implacable que
presionaba constantemente a los
funcionarios para asegurarse de que las
cosas se hicieran su trabajo en la
capital de la provincia a laure donde
supervisó varios proyectos de
infraestructura de gran envergadura le
genera una cuota de admiradores pero sus
críticos le acusan de corrupción y de
querer convertir pakistán en un feudo
familiar siendo se basaría una de las
principales figuras que pidieron una
moción de censura contra imran khan